- This is so crazy for me
to hear all these details
'cause I've never talked
to a composer ever.
So this is just so cool to get these
inside look to everything.
- Hi, I'm Michael Abels,
the composer of "Nope".
- Yo, everybody, my name is Brandon Perea.
I play Angel Torres in "Nope"
- And this is "Trade Secrets".
(soft music)
- Michael Abels.
- Brandon, great to meet you.
- Great to meet you in person, finally.
We've been Instagram
friends for a little while
and I'm definitely a fan.
So it's cool to be sitting here right now
across from you and I'm
just so thankful to be here.
- Thank you, likewise, likewise.
I've really been enjoying
watching your performance
for all these months as we
work on post production.
- Thank you so much.
Like, I've been a fan of you, of course,
since "Get Out", "Us" and now
you're doing "Nope" as well.
It's just incredible the
scores that you've crafted
and I use them a lot in my social settings
like when we're playing this game
- Really?
- Called "Mafia"
I love to play the "Get Out" score
or the "Us" score 'cause it
really brings in the tone
of like, this serious, spooky vibe.
- Oh, that's so cool.
- Yeah, so that's definitely
something I utilize
in my social gatherings.
(Michael chuckling)
- Wow.
- So, thank you
for providing that, truly.
- Absolutely.
- How did you get involved
with Jordan first?
I don't know the story, so I'm excited
to hear how you got involved with Jordan.
- I have been writing music all my life
and especially music for orchestra.
I wrote a lot of concert music, you know,
for in the concert hall.
Some of that was on YouTube.
It had a couple dozen hits.
One of 'em was Jordan when he was lookin'
for someone to score "Get Out".
And he was looking for, I think, someone
who could write in really scary style
but also who understood the
African American experience.
So he had the producers hunt
me down and took a meeting.
- That's incredible.
- Isn't it?
- That was Jordan's
introduction into filming.
Was it your introduction
into filmmaking, as well?
- I had done, you know,
some commercials and stuff
in college, but had not really made
any headway in the industry.
So to get a call from Jordan Peele
out of the blue was really a dream.
- Wow, all right, 'cause
this is insane to me.
I'm actually learning
stuff as we're talking.
I just listened to the
score recently for "Nope"
and it's another home run.
And it's so different
from "Get Out" and "Us".
'Cause you know, Jordan's
kind of crafted this film
on a grander scale, it's very big.
And I feel like you have
just done that with sound
and the instruments you've chosen.
- [Michael] Well, thank you.
- It's so great to get a new kind of style
and edge from you, and also
where you still sprinkle
in, like, your little things that you do
with like, the little,
the shadow of sounds
of (whispering) that's a, he's a.
Like, I hear a couple
of those and I'm like,
"Oh, that's Abel's man."
But then I'm like, "But
this is so different."
It's just so cool to see
you both grow as artists.
And as a fan, I'm just so pleased to be
in a film that you're scoring.
- It was clear that the film
was a lot bigger in scale
than any of the others,
and so it was important
that the sound, the music
stepped that up too,
and fill that space, and really play
into what a big summer movie needs to be,
but in the world of Jordan Peele,
which no one has seen yet.
- Jordan has his style of filmmaking
and you have your style of composing,
and I feel like them together
is just ultimate power
of artists coming together.
- Well, I've got a question for you.
As an actor, we haven't
met, even though we've been
on socials, but I feel like I know you
only because part of my job
is to watch your performance
in the film as I'm scoring it.
A lotta times I don't meet the actor
until it's at the premier party.
And I'm like, "Hey, how you doin'?"
And they're like, "Who is this guy?"
But I'm wondering when you see the film
and you hear the music, like,
what does the music provide
for an actor's experience of the film
and what's that like for you?
- Oh, score is so important.
It's key for an audience member.
And that's what's crazy
about being an actor.
You're so locked in to
the dialog that goin' on.
You're having a conversation,
you're acting, performing.
All these emotions are running.
But it's silent and then
when you hear scores
subtly in there and then it kinda grows
into this grand scale, it just
helps storytelling so much.
And it's one of the key
components of filmmaking.
There's times where it can go
over the general public's head,
like, they don't know
that that's even going on.
But that's causing emotion for them.
You know, it raises the stakes.
I was watching dailies from "Nope"
and where I'm just watching
little quick cuts and edits.
And then it's without score and I'm like,
"Oh, wow, this is great."
Like, "Aw, amazing."
And then score's involved and I'm like,
"How'd this get better?"
There's so many historical sounds
that have been created through composing.
And I feel like that's
what you've done with this.
It's crazy hearing pieces
in this room, like,
"Oh wow, these sounds are
gonna live on forever."
- All of Jordan's movies
contain some kind of satire
of something, you know.
So the Jupiter's Claim theme
park was a great chance
to provide a soundtrack
for this theme park
that doesn't really exist.
But in Jordan's world, we
play it like it's legit.
So it was great to act
like that was a real thing.
I feel really lucky when
I get to collaborate
with him and help him.
These crazy ideas that he
comes up with them them seem
as real as they are when he thinks 'em up.
- Do actors' performances
kind of inspire certain sounds
or instruments that you like to bring in
in order to display it, to
get a performance going?
Like, is there anything that--?
- Yeah, for sure.
The actors, you know,
most of composer talks
with the director about what
he or she wants for the film.
Every director has a really
specific idea of music
that they begin with and
they work with the composer
to help find the unique
score to their film.
Thinking about your performance,
like, your character.
So we've never talked
about your character,
but when I just watch your
performance, I get about him
like, what a hopeful guy Angel is.
I just feel like his life
is filled with possibility.
He has just gone through a bad time,
but now he's got this thing
that's fascinating him
and he's really lit up by it.
And I get that not in the script,
it's just from, you know,
watching your performance.
And I can't even explain how I feel that
but it was from watching you.
It was a couple of scenes
where Jordan's instructions
to me was that it's a bad miracle
and you gotta be able to have music
that's one part, "Oh (beep),"
and one part, "oh my god."
And so the music I'm doing
is trying to do that.
The look on your face in
the couple of those scenes,
I was like, that's the thing
that I need to capture in music.
What that actor's doing is the thing
that's my job to reinforce.
- It's crazy to hear this.
This is so crazy for me
to hear all these details
'cause I've never talked
to a composer ever.
So this is just so cool to get these
inside looks to everything.
You played that line so well
where you gave all these emotions
and it was just so crazy to hear a score
where it's like you're giving all hope.
And then there's times
where you take it away.
- Yep.
- In the sound.
And it's so, it's like creepy-crawly
like, ants on my back.
I'm like, "Oh, that's
scary, that's scary."
- Jordan really uses the slowdown
of music and sound as a
warning sign to let you know
that something really
bad's about to happen.
- It's so cool to even be a part of one
of the projects that you both are on.
It's insane.
I'm so glad to be having
this conversation with you.
I think a lot of your work
is just, it lives on forever.
Truly, like what you've
done with the score
of "Get Out" especially,
it's just, it's so good.
And it's just sounds that people
will resonate with forever.
Those sounds that you've
crafted, those haunting sounds
and those beats and drums.
All those sounds together?
It's gonna live on forever, truly.
- One of the conversations
I have with Jordan is
about rhythm because the
rhythms are really important.
But you know, some rhythms
make you wanna dance
and some let you know that
something bad's about to happen
and maybe you oughta run and not dance.
The difference between those
is kinda slight sometimes,
so I'm always, when I'm
coming up with rhythms
I wanna be ones that make
people wanna dance a little.
And sometimes he'll say, "Mm,
that's not scary enough."
You know?
- Oh, yeah?
- And I have to go back and I'll make it
less dance and more scary.
- I love the ones that
are kind of both though,
where it's like you have that rhythmic.
It's like, "Oh, it's comin', it's comin'."
Then it's just like, "Nevermind."
Like, "Oh, okay, I gotta go, I gotta go."
- Okay, well I'm right with you
because I think that dance
rhythms can be scary too.
This has been such a pleasure, I just.
- Yeah, cheers man.
- Just thank you.
- Thank you for chatting with me.
It's great that our first
time meeting is documented.
And yeah, I'm just so grateful to be here.
It's crazy to me, I'm talking
to Michael Abel, "Nope" is here.
In the movie, it's a dream,
this is bigger than a dream.
Like, you know, our movie
thing is a bad miracle,
this is the greatest
miracle of all time for me.